Ah 1
Yes Hello, it is a forced theory to be announced on the subject of JavaScript asynchronous processing for smooth Lex. It is a
great honor to be in a position to share this content with you, and that position is also a js comp loop.
Even such a small thing  There are also commonalities.
Uh So, the contents of today's announcement are going to be discussed in this flow.
Uh, what kind of problem should we talk about first? Let
's analyze the cause and find some solutions based on the cause.  I'm
going to deal with the
problems that I often face when using web applications, such as scrolling during use,
typing limits not being reflected directly on the screen,
implemented animations not working smoothly, or
Bing, etc.  I think it can be said to be representative examples that hinder the usability of web services. There
can be many causes that cause these problems.
First of all, the implementation itself may be wrong, or there may be problems with the running environment.
Ah, but  This time, I'm going to analyze the cause focusing on these things.
Ah, run compilation, one of the characteristics of the JavaScript language,
JavaScript engine that runs JavaScript code, call stack event loop, etc.  I would like to
suggest some solutions based on the causes.
Before getting into the full-scale content, I would like to ask you that what I
will explain is not a clear solution, but a
process of finding a better solution to a problem.  I would appreciate it if you could understand.
First of all, what is user experience?
I am neither an ex designer nor an expert in the field,
so I am somewhat cautious, but I
dare to think about what user experience is.
If not, what do the requirements problems have in common? It
is that the interaction intended by the user, such as page loading, typing, animation, did not respond in time.  It
could be a factor.
If so, what caused these problems?
Some one action doesn't work in time, so you can suspect that something is blocking and slowing down that action.  Let's take a
look at how it works.
First, let's take a look at the feature of runt compilation, and then we'll eat it all up and move on. Then,
compilation means that a message is
ironed out.  It
means that you can't get in the middle. Let's
take a look at the example code.
What will happen
if you run this code?  I
checked, but it will still be a tour.
After that, it will print a running message to the console,
and after 1 500 milliseconds, the running will still be a tour.  As
you all know, it is an icon that appears when the chrome tab process gives it.
As a * character, you should understand the runt complete ya well and
do well not to encounter this icon. So I just showed you the process of executing example code to explain the runt condition.
In the JavaScript lens, there is a place that acts as a cursor that indicates the location when the code is executed like this.
This is the call stack.
In JavaScript, whenever a request comes in, the request
remains in the calling world sequentially and is processed. For
example,  What function has been called and is currently running,
what function is called next, etc. I'm going to have a
hello call that has a code that prints a message to say hello,
call that hello function, and js company didn't take 3 days to write a message.  This
is the code that organizes the number of hello js confirmations that have code and calls the 4 comp function of hello js at the end.  It will be
stacked and it will be
stacked by calling the Fellows s comp function.
Then it will call the Hello function and
request to print the Tello message to the console.
Then, by printing the Hello message, the story will be grown and the
js that was located after the Helm output  Comp Korea
Requested another j Compria Remove it from the stack while making a request to take a message.
After that, the function's s COMP js Company 3 will also be used, so I
will choose it again and become me.
Then, after everything is done, the main block  In
this way, JavaScript operates in the Gaunt compilation method along with the call stack structure.
Uh, then, what would be the problem when it operates in this way? Let's
look at this situation hypothetically.
What will happen if you encounter a task with some
delay while processing one after the other  There
will be a terrain since you shoot a message to the company.
If so, I have a question here. It is said that
JavaScript handles multiple tasks with a single call stack structure.
In the meantime, I don't think that data is arranged and spread on the screen, and
tasks are being processed while waiting sequentially.
Then, how are you handling these complex concurrency issues?
Give me the api used to call the web page pi that helps with the solution Tia xmlhttp request a6 that helps with the solution
There must be things like 3 timeout tomis 2 cast animation frame that handles timers, uh, these are things that are hard to use in modern web development,
and  Now, in the next chapter, the explanations are more focused on events. These
two things make it possible to do asynchronous programming using JavaScript,
so let's take a closer look at the event loop.
In mdn, the event loop is as follows
Assuming that the apo message function operates synchronously, it
seems to be a code that waits for a message while looping and processes the next message if there is a message. An
event loop is a component of the JavaScript engine.
This means that support for asynchronous concurrency is
not the JavaScript engine, but the environment in which the engine runs,
such as a browser or node race.  If there is a
task, the oldest task is executed, and if there is
no task, the tech waits for the task, and if there is a task, it
goes back to normal and repeats.  Let's
look at the event loop in more detail through the code using the web api that handles the
nest.
If there is no argument like , the default value is English.
Uh, the timer time is lost in English. It
seems like it should be executed immediately, but in reality it is
not.  Below that,
there is an api that handles the situation of future completion or failure of an asynchronous operation when an
asynchronous operation is processed.
It will pass the callback of the time. Let's take a look. If
you look at it, you have to call 3 timeouts first.
Yes, put that callback in the task queue.
Then, call the Promise and call the
Rodin
method.  But if you look at it, you
can see that it is just handed over to a slightly different confrontation,
such as a
queue.  I lost it to point out the difference for a moment.
A task means a task that needs to be executed sequentially in a browser or other operating environment.
Uh, simply executing a script, or 3 timeout or
callback due to ui rent generation, etc. can be the source.
Yes, microtask
refers to an asynchronous task that should be executed immediately after the currently running task. In other words, microtask
has a high priority of no task.  The
same
things become the source.
Well, then, if you come back to the cleanup after the event I mentioned earlier,
it seems that there is a part to elaborate a little. If
you look at it, before waiting for a task, first check if there is a micro task, and if
all the micro tests are empty, then the task
Then, if you return to the example code earlier, you will finally be able to see that you regret the event.
Then,
based on the understanding of the event loop,
can all problems be solved by using the web akb that handles flying dragons?
Unfortunately, I don't think so.
The possibility of being blocked
remains. Let's
take a look. As in the previous example,
call 3 timeout, put that callback in the task key,
call [music] and pumis, and
cerebral bobby yung.  I
will put the callback to be performed in the microtask queue. As I
said, the microtask has a higher priority, so
after the event, the high-volume task is pushed to the prestep first,
so the task that prints your hello is
the event
Of course, when the task is completed, it can be executed then.  Since the
child is executed sequentially,
no other task can be executed until a random task is frozen.
Since microtask q has a higher priority than normal task q, something like an event occurs until the microtask queue is empty.
That is,
if something that takes a long time to execute, for example,
tasks or microtasks involving high-cost calculations of CPU pounds are being executed,
events such as click text or rendering that are directly related to fish child can be blocked,
which is the user experience  It can be a factor that harms it.
Then, how can I solve the phenomenon you mentioned? I'll
give you something together with the prepared demo.
If you
take a look at the g-code gathered to see how it works, it
is a simple code. Whenever a text frame event occurs,
htm for square elements of a random color proportional to the number of characters entered is generated.  It's a code that sprays on the screen. The
point here seems to be two things.
Mom is running an iteration, and
uh, and the cost of updating the dome of the money is high.
It seems to be enough to be an expensive operation
Oh, then let's take a look at the demo at the same time. If
you look at it, it's a simple ui.
Proportional
number of darkness will be updated on the screen, and
uh, boi, I'll be user interaction here. It's an
animation that reflects well when I enter text.
I'll write down a message
4 If you look at it, I typed up to one j while typing the text, but the text is cut off
and the animation can't be cut off.
After a while, you can see that he & children are reflected.
So, it is the result of profiling, but it
looks a bit complicated, but I think you can see two big things here. First of all, it is the
area at the top of the frame.  If you look at , you
can see the results of up-analysis related to user interaction. The red sales in the orange block
mean the time required to pass through the main staff 3 red for user
interaction.  I
can confirm that it took a considerable amount of time for each step,
so maybe the solutions I'll introduce next should be a way to minimize these things. There are
two main ways I suggest.
One is a single call stack structure and an event.  Since there is a block in Hu, etc., there is a
way to delegate work to another thread, that is,
if multi-threading 2 is possible in JavaScript, there will be a way to use it.  This
is how to do it.
Multi-threading in JavaScript is possible by using web butter.
Everker enables script execution on a separate background system rather than the main thread.
Based on this, communication becomes possible.
Through a post message, a worker thread is requested to execute a long-running task, and the
children who cut something execute it. At this time, the main thread does not block because of this.
The work is completed  If so, it will eventually send completion through the poster message, and you
will be able to do something else through the work of the main thread.
Request this long run task through the message method, and for the cut, now the
work on the worker cell is completed, so it will be a code that waits for a message and then handles it.
I'll write it down. Something seems to be a little better than before.
But it seems that there is still a feeling of stuttering.
Uh, then I'll take a look at the profiling result of the demo that I improved by applying the method.  ,
and you
can see that a significant portion of the interaction time is included.
However, as confirmed in the main gate, this method
does not seem to have a user experience without stuttering at
all.
Considering that it is shown on the basis of the first length, it
takes up to 600 milliseconds and 900 milliseconds as much as 900
milliseconds.  This
seems to be the case because it
recovers that communication between the main thread and the worker thread is only possible based on messages,
which means that the worker cannot directly access the context of the domina or the main thread.  There
seems to be a way to properly execute it.
Well, if you briefly look at the
cool knife, it will feel like this
Did you listen to the data-related session on that channel earlier?  I do
n't know if it's true, but if you look at it differently from the existing code that
performs the action immediately when an input event is triggered, you
can see that the chunk generator of the interface called Cheongsu is called and passed on.
There is a pattern to yield for each unit. It
seems that Arron Cheongsu plays a role in loading the yielded work into the task queue through an asynchronous ak, such as the new file mark I mentioned earlier.  I'll try and
write down the same message as v
4 Relatively
text Eames seems to have swept a lot of blocks, but I
can see that something is happening at once because rendering is pushed back
2 At least text in fuson is not highlighted
Likewise, let's take a look at the pro sales results.
Uh, I think we can see that a significant part of the numerical improvement has also been improved.  It would be
nice to approach it in a way that minimizes the god. The
daemon is updated as an independent animal according to the text inflation. In the
case of typing quickly like Marka, it
would be okay to update the water only at the last moment rather than renewing help every time.
When is initially a large chunk, the next task is blocked, so it
would not be possible to perform the task by determining whether to update or not.
After that, it says that it is in progress, so you
can cancel the task and start a new task.
The graph sold by , has also become quite neat. The
application's maximum required time also took a little while at the moment of updating the last tom, the rest of the
frames are compliant, and
the time required for terrorism interaction has become noticeably shorter.  Let's see,
if a task or microtask with a long execution time blocks rendering mobs
such as imp, a
lie that harms the user experience can be delivered to the user.  It is important to
understand this well and
handle it appropriately,
and to solve this, it is important to assign a long run-in task to a background thread such as an external boker,
or to ensure that it is properly executed on the side with a small task so that
y rent is not blocked.  It's good if you don't.
Well, as the saying goes, the
best optimization is to do nothing. It's
right to avoid expensive calculations or excessive Dong Deng as much as possible.
Even if it is a code, I thought that it would make a
difference between a code written knowing how the code works and how the composition environment is composed, and a code
that is not.